or
to this meeting of the council
and
those that have
just logging in
will carry on as uh
before you
complete
um
i am councillor adrian osborne
chairman of gaber district council
and i will be chairing this meeting
today
may i first of all remind you
of some domestic arrangements
all right okay yep sorry
i was going to stand up there
no no
there's all the space
no okay
um
so may i first to uh
may i first uh remind you of some of our
domestic arrangements
toilets are situated
outside in the corridor
opposite the stairs
cold water
is also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound
please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the ipswich
town football club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
to
it's safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
robert
i would like to remind everyone present
that this informal meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to this to
the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
council members of the public and the
press
may record
film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
finally
can i ask all councillors
to speak directly into their microphones
and
and refrain
from covering the microphones with their
papers when speaking
touche
sorry to interrupt did i miss here or
did you say this informal meeting at the
beginning of your preamble and i thought
it was a formal meeting
yeah sorry my mistake it should be
formal thank you thank you
thank you guys on the call
um
so having gone through that can i move
to the agenda please and can i ask all
counsellors
to ensure
that their questions and debate
are concise
to the point and not a repeat of other
questions
and comments
apologies for absence
thank you chair i've received apologies
for absence from councillors fraser
grandin and councillor gould
um thanks thanks jan for all of that
i would like to send on behalf of the
council
all our best wishes
uh to catherine
and a speedy return to the council
chamber
thank you
are there any declarations of interest
council mabry
um thank you chairman um it's just to
declare that i am a director of sudbury
sit down
and district citizens advice because
it's mentioned within the paperwork
thank you under the overview and
scrutiny report thank you
are there any other declarations
i shall move on to
number
item
3
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 2nd of november 2021
for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
could i please have a proposal
counselor airs
and
could i have a sector please
thank you john ward
thank you
i will now ask a corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the vote
thank you chair as this is um for the
minutes and it's a consensus vote can
you do this by show of hands all those
in favor please
thank you chair that is carried
all right thank you very much
um i'll now turn to item 4 bc 2124
announcements from the chairman and
leader
i refer you to papers bc2124 for noting
thank you
council ward
oh that's me first and then
um
i have i have my paper there noted on on
the um
visits i've made on civic uh duties
i must say are a bit disappointed
on that i haven't been able to attend as
many as i wish to
due to the present
epidemic and also some being cancelled
at the last minute
council war do you have anything to
report
yes i do chairman
firstly i'd like to say a few words
about the current covert situation the
omicron variant produced a very rapid
rise in infections over the christmas
holiday period
due to its much greater personal
closeness much greater transmissibility
and then we saw a cos corresponding
rapid decline over a fortnight to less
than half the the peak rate
however that was last week and the
infection rate is now rising again the
situation is still uncertain and whilst
the relaxing of restrictions is welcome
and probably right we must still take
care and follow the basic rules maintain
distance wash hands regularly and wear
masks but there's absolutely no doubt
that the vaccination program is working
and i can personally attest to that
a couple of weeks ago we had an
excellent all member briefing from the
environment team highlighting the huge
amount of progress that has had that has
been made towards our net zero by 2030
target
i thought it would be an opportune
moment to highlight the key achievements
so far
and the single biggest contribution has
of course been the replacement of diesel
with hbo in our vehicle fleet our
vehicles were accounting for 25.9 of the
total co2 emissions of the two councils
a total of 730 solar panels have been
installed on our two leisure centers and
at the women wenham depot
the vapor leisure centers were
accounting for 18.9 percent of the two
councils co2 emissions
a new filtration system
saving both energy and water has been
installed at the kingfisher leisure
center in sudbury solar carports have
been installed in station road car park
in sudbury
across the two districts we have
installed solar panels on 2000 castle
houses and 250 more now have air source
heat pumps
all new homes delivered for council
housing last year were built an epc
rating of b
we have undertaken the tree canopy
survey and biodiversity mapping exercise
and
this is quite um pertinent following on
from council air council airs
earlier reflection prior to the saturn
meeting
last year 281 trees were planted and 4
690 hedgerow plants distributed to towns
and parishes and this is only the start
of a long-term program to increase our
tree canopy
although we have been successful in
getting grants for a lot of this it has
all nonetheless been achieved with
within its within our budget
and also without spending on things that
won't provide a measurable impact just
as this administration promised when we
developed our carbon reduction
management and biodiversity action plans
in addition to the things we're doing
for our district we are working with our
partners in the county to support the
delivery of the suffolk climate
emergency plan
and we are also helping our businesses
and communities to reduce their carbon
footprint starting with last year's
first low energy showcase event at
western park
we are now awaiting clarification of
some of the details concerning the
government's resources and waste
strategy
i think it is fair to say that all local
authorities have serious concerns about
implementation and costs and i really
hope that we will be listened to as we
the districts and county are the ones
responsible for collection and disposal
following on from the announcement
or the release of the leveling up white
paper this morning i'm pleased to inform
you that the government has announced
that suffolk has been offered a county
deal
within the existing local government
structure
as part of the leveling up white paper
and this follows the expression of
interest submitted by suffolk public
sector leaders last year
there will be a lot more to report on
this as the details emerge in the weeks
to come but i do want to stress that
this does not mean a single county
unitary combined authority with norfolk
or an elected mayor
but back to covert it is great that for
the first council meeting of 2022 we are
meeting in person in our chamber
i sincerely hope that this marks an
irreversible return to normal
there is a lot to do this year and we
need to focus on that
so let's look forward to a much better
2022 when we are finally able to resume
our lives without the fear of further
disruption albeit almost certainly
having to live with covid as an endemic
disease with annual boosters
thank you chairman
to be raised
councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman uh if um council
wall could just run over the
offer that the government has put
forward again because it appeared to be
absolutely nothing
so and who was consulted on
uh the proposals that were being put
forward to government uh wasn't just the
leaders or did they actually speak to
their councils
there is nothing so far that's been put
forward by government uh it's it's all
very early stages um the initial uh
offer from government last year was to
ask if any counties would like to
expression it express an interest in
what they call a county deal the details
of that are yet to emerge
the suffolk public sector leaders
provided
a summary uh response to that expression
of interest saying we were interested
and we now are in a position where we
can take this forward because the
government government has accepted us as
one of the um i think it's nine areas to
take forward for a county deal and we
await to
find out and negotiate the detail with
government
sorry mr chairman but uh
so we actually expressed an interest in
something we hadn't a clue what it was
all about
other than the fact that uh
clearly that the whole idea is to
devolve uh
funding and uh responsibility for a
number of things to
uh that the county um
and uh with that with us with suffolk
with the districts as well through
suffolk public sector leaders we don't
know the details yet no i'm sorry i
can't report any more i said i will be
reporting in future as soon as i hear
there any further information but at the
moment that's
we're at the table where we can talk
that's all
thank you council award
moving on to item five to receive
notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council procedure
rules
thank you chair long received
thank you jan
item
six
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedure rules
thank you chair non-received thank you i
now turn to i item eight
number seven oh number seven sorry
questions by councillors in accordance
with council procedure rules
no receipt chat
i now turn to our domain
bc 2125
overview and scrutiny committee report
i would like to invite council mclaren
to introduce paper bc 2125
which is for noting
thank you
thank you uh mr chairman
members have got in front of them quite
a comprehensive report by me
which reflects the two meetings that
took place one looking at the shared
legal service and the second one looking
at citizens advice
across the district
i'm happy if everybody's feels happy
that they've read it i will be
very happy to take any of your questions
i would like to just advise members
that overview and scrutiny are looking
at changing
some of the subjects that they
scrutinize
i think there has over a period of years
been a routine rollover of programme
and so we're trying to
embrace other subjects other than
some of the main subjects that we've
always reviewed
but happy to take questions mr chairman
thank you
thank you mr chairman um
just a quick one on the review of the
shared legal services
uh it talks about the service reported
to a steering committee that had
representatives from all three councils
and also reported to leadership teams in
each authority
presumably that's officers officers and
officers nothing to do with members
yes that's and um can i just say council
hinton that uh
emily you always is a member of that
steering committee but it doesn't
involve councillors it is officers
thank you
council mclaren
are there any other questions
council maybe
thank you thank you mr chairman um i
don't know if i'm allowed to ask the
question so i'm going to ask the
monitoring officer can i ask a question
about citizens advice or not i can
thank you very much and my question is
the overview and scrutiny
committee
looked at their work and thank you for
that
i do remember
two years ago
that the amount of money that baber
would be giving to citizens advice would
be increased on a percentage
and that hasn't happened
and i wondered if you could explain why
please thank you thank you
thank you um
councillor mabry this was discussed
actually at our meeting
and you will see that one of the
recommendations we made was that the um
annual payment would be
index linked
i have no idea why
um
that has not in the past
has been implemented but we made another
recommendation to both cabinets
um about that
thank you mr chen um just to come back
because the index linking wasn't done
um is there any chance that um the
difference but over the last two years
would be forwarded as the back payment
please
thank you
councillor maybe i take note of what
you're concerned about you will also see
that i made an additional recommendation
for
uh sudbury citizens advice i've still
got to follow that through we've still
got to follow that through through with
cabinet
but i was very concerned about the
amount of debt advice
that the suburban citizen's advice were
undertaking
with limited resources so i hope
that's reassured you that and i will
pursue your concern thank you
thank you council maybe that was a
question for cabinet so
thank you council mclaren for that
recommendations from cabinet
committees
um
you know yeah sorry i've got got a bit
confused here
um
9a
jace ac 2110
half year report on treasury management
2021
22.
i would like to invite councilli huron
to introduce this item and to move the
recommendation in the report thank you
councillor
thank you
yeah we have liftoff that's fine
thank you councillor macron
must be the cold weather or the wind we
have liftoff at last thank you um
just a brief
introduction of our work which is for
noting
um this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position for the
first six months
of the financial year 2122
it provides details of performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period
and compliance with the council's
treasury management policy
the report explains the factors
affecting the strategy and activities
including the regulatory framework
economic conditions
interest rate and liquidity liquidity
risk
interest rates during the year continued
at very low levels
and the bank of england base right
remained at one tenth of one percent
the economic recovery from the
coronavirus pandemic continued to
dominate the first half of the financial
year
the easing of restrictions boosted
activity in the second quarter of the
calendar
helping push gdp up by five and a half
percent quarter on quarter
the employment rate increased and
economic activity rates decreased
suggesting an improved labor market
picture
annual cpi inflation rose to 3.2 percent
in august
and the boe now expects inflation to
exceed four percent for the end of the
calendar year which is the one just gone
owing largely to developments in energy
and goods prices
more specifically specifically for our
council
as highlight highlighted in appendix c
paragraph 5 4 there was one occasion
where baber exceeded its
daily bank account limit with lloyds by
136k
this was due to lloyd's online banking
system being available for the day
meaning no balances could be invested
the council has in fact reduced its
debts by 5.4 million
the investment activities untaken were
in accordance with the approved
counterparty list
the council's investment activities
including average returns
can be found at appendix c
of this report
investment in the funding circle has
reduced as allocated funds have been
reclaimed and existing loans repaid
investment is reduced by 31k leaving the
balance at the 30th of september as 135
k
the council is compliant with the upper
limits for interest rate exposure
the investment activity undertaken for
the half year was done so in priority
order of security and liquidity over
yield as prescribed in the treasury
management strategy
the paper chairman is for noting but
willing to take any um
questions and if i can't answer them i
see that catherine and rebecca
are in attendance i believe to
answer the difficult bits but as chair i
certainly will do my best
it's been a pretty busy year for us i
would say and
times are difficult but
i'm confident in saying we've done all
the right things at the right time
we've complied with everything
and as a district council i think we
should
be quite proud of that
thank you chairman
thank you councillor haran
could i have a sector
council award
do you wish to speak
thank you
we've now moved to
questions
councils may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion and must be a
question
thank you
councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman um
two two points really uh firstly
on page
32 of the report
um
paragraph 2.14
there's a lot of information about the
latest labour market data and all the
rest of it which i assume applies to the
whole country is it possible to have
something more relevant to this district
that we know what's happening in our own
district rather than the country as a
whole because obviously that's what
we're more interested in and secondly
when it comes to the loans on page
there's so much paperwork here on page
38 of the report paragraph 1.6 table 3
with the chart
i assume they do not include the cifco
debt which of course is considerably
larger than anything that's actually
done down there
chairman on the second one i think i can
be confident and say and no it doesn't
um relate to the cifco debt that is
something quite separate
um i i do believe the first one it's a
national figure whether we could
extrapolate replicate a local one i'm
not so sure i think it would be
difficult um
i'm not too sure if rebecca or catherine
could
help on that one
thank you chair um we'll have a look
again i'm not sure whether we can get
that data down at the local level but we
will have a look and see see whether
that is available um and just if i may
take the opportunity while i've just got
the floor the um debt that is referred
to in the charts it is inclusive of
external debt that we have got
specifically because it is the whole
borrowing of baber district council so
it is both housing debt and general fund
debt
yes
the loans the loans that baber make to
sifko is part of that when we've gone
external and borrowed from pwlb
thank you thank you mr chairman um now
this
this may it will be a question that
everyone says why are you asking that um
but 5.4 it says that
the daily bank account limit with lloyds
was exceeded by 136
000.
um could the monitoring officer answer
two questions on that the first is is
that a minus or a positive
and the second is if it was a minus
did lloyd's bank charge any interest
thank you
thank you chair thank you for the
questions and it was the fact that we
ended up with slightly more in our bank
account with lloyds than we should do so
um if you take that as a as a positive i
suppose because it was more money in the
account
and
because of that no they don't charge us
interest because it's money in the
account rather than it being an
overdrawn account
maybe uh thank you very much mr chairman
if i may just come back on that um i
think it would be useful
for councillors that if this happened in
the future it was actually marked as
whether it was a positive or negative
thank you
if that's possible catherine thank you
councillor lindsay
thank you chair um
yes just following up on sifko
if it's
if it's there were two questions really
um
if it's gonna if it's part of our debt
perhaps it could be um broken out in the
figures what what that is
and the second question a bit more
complicated
but
um
when i've tried to ask about
sifko and auditing cifco in um
in audit before i've been told that
we're not allowed to look at it the
audit committee
just wondered why that was
thanks
catherine would you
well brynn
yeah i think chair i'll have to defer on
to either to dave busby or catherine
steele on that one everything
i'll try first chair um in terms of the
last point about order of cifco uh sifco
is a
wholly owned company so it has got its
own auditors so they are the people who
are externally appointed by the civco
board to look at civco's accounts
obviously their reports on the are
published on companies house so once
that has been
enacted then it is publicly available
but that's why
joint audit and standards don't have the
overview and our external auditors ey
don't audit civco's accounts but they do
look at sifko's
element in our accounts because we have
to prepare group accounts because of the
company status with civco so that
element ey do do look at
in terms of the civco debt then there
may be something in the report
and there's a lot of appendices in this
report and i haven't had the time just
to scan it to see whether that is is
explicit but if not we'll bear that in
mind for future reports
thank
you there any other questions
councilman crawl it's just on that last
point about the examination of sifko it
is subject sorry i apologize i forgotten
we need we are allowed to stand up again
so i apologize chair
but that is subject to an annual
scrutiny process and auditing standards
is a scrutiny process of one type but in
the case of cifco that's always been
subject to an annual scrutiny process
since the institution of civico and it's
been quite exhaustive over those years
so i think those questions could be
answered through the next annual process
any other questions
all right as the questions are finished
we will now move to the bait debate
counselors will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
who would like to start the debate
nope
no debate
counselor harren
do you wish to add anything
no i think chair um
regard what i said and the questions and
it is all in the papers anyway um
you know enough has been said i am the
proposer and happy to do so thank you
thank you
um
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electric electronic vote
thank you
thank you chair councillors that vote is
now showing in blue if you could cast
your vote please thank you
um
councillor lindsay we all need to take
your vote um verbally
thank you
cancer carp and dale are you able to
vote would you like me to take it
verbally
sorry yes um for
my the screen's frozen sorry i can't do
a thing with it okay
and counsellor nun
thank you
chair that is 28 4 and 1 abstention so
that is carried
thank you
the uh that is carried
um
right 9b
uh update from
a verbal update from chair of license in
the regulatory
committee i would like to invite
councillor maybe to provide her verbal
update
uh thank you very much mr chairman um
yes indeed the um the licensing and
regulatory committee met on the 10th of
december and we discussed the no
casino
proposal
this was not
agreed
we decided that it would be best left as
it is
the issues are the casino
no
no casino resolution would only last for
three years
there is no hope sadly for some
that of us get invader getting a casino
license the licenses are
set out by central government they are
allocated and we do not have any
so it was decided by the committee that
this would not be a suitable resolution
to put forward that
a no casino resolution should be
approved at council so it has been left
in abeyance we did actually look at the
positives perhaps if casinos ever did
come to suffolk
would there be an increase in nighttime
activity would there be a financial gain
for the district this was all looked at
but it was um decided to leave it in a
balance that there would be
no ruling on it thank you
thank you council maybe
are there any questions for councilman
mayberry
so we move on to the next item which is
uh
10.
oh sorry
counselor but sorry
what happened to debate um just a
thought since we're producing a cultural
strategy should this not be part of that
thank you very much councillor um what
do you mean by cultural strategy
would you like to expand that further
because then i would be able to answer i
think more fully thank you
well it's it's early days yet but um
it's looking at the arts culture
of the district
determining how we should be going
forward in that where we should be
investing
and i would have thought casinos could
come under that
as part of our strategy
thank you but but to come back again to
you
councillor busby um we do not have any
allocations for any licenses
so we can't have a we cannot have a
casino the government only puts out so
many allocations we don't have any and
there was a review in the look house of
lords
and there was a lot of negative talk
about casinos and as far as the
information that we had gathered there
would not be any further allocations of
casinos so thank you for explaining your
position and hopefully i've explained
the position of the committee thank you
thank you councillor maybe councillor
moghazi
thank you mr chairman um
councillor mayberry actually answered
the question
that i was going to voice
thank you
thank you
no other questions uh i shall move on to
the
item 10 bc 2126
the development of housing revenue
account business plans
and i would like to invite councillor
jan osborne to introduce a paper bc 2126
and to move the recommendations in this
report
thank you mr chairman
good evening everyone the housing
revenue account hra is the financial
account used to manage our landlord
activities it is ring fenced in law and
can only be used for providing services
to council housing tenants through the
collection of rent and charges
other council services are funded
through council tax and central
government support which benefit all
citizens labor regardless excuse me of
tenure
the hra business plan which is in
development will set out our income and
expenditure plans for delivering council
housing services as well as setting out
our key council housing priorities for
the forth coming years and demonstrating
how we intend to develop our services to
meet tenants expectations
this is timely work as we look to the
introduction of the social housing white
paper which sets out the actions the
government will take to ensure that
residents in social housing are safe
are listened to
live in good quality homes and have
access to redress when things go wrong
the building safety bill which is the
next step in groundbreaking reforms to
give residents and homeowners more
rights powers and protections making
homes across the country safer
this will overhaul regulations creating
lasting generational changes setting out
a clear pathway on how residential
buildings should be constructed
maintained and made safe
this is alongside the introduction of
our council's outcomes framework and the
development of our new build design
guide and technical specification
as well as a midpoint review of our
homes and housing strategy
excuse me an associated action plan
during the past few months we have been
listening to our stakeholders to develop
our approach to the plan
members will recall being invited to
respond to a survey
and we have also used last year's
members workshops and the work which
centered on a stock take to contribute
to the priorities that we have
established for this plan
this report sets out the approach that
has been taken and identifies the areas
of focus most important to everyone and
which will be incorporated into the
plans
over the next couple of months we will
be finalizing the plan with the
intention of the final version of the
hra business plan being presented to
full council for comment
moving forward each year the hra
business plan will be reviewed and
updated to set budgets and charges for
the year ahead whilst providing an
updated five-year plan for our capital
investment program
mr chairman i would like to propose
recommendations as set up in this report
and ask for a seconder 3.1 to note this
report 3.2 approve the creation of a new
hr business case myself and the
assistant director
of housing gavin fisk is here to answer
any questions
as many questions as they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion and must be a
question
anybody for the questions council
jameson
thank you uh
uh mr chair
um
on section i wonder for class on section
4.19 it says an emphasis on good quality
design energy efficiency
low running costs sustainability and use
of modern methods of construction where
appropriate i just wonder where if you
can explain where good quality design
and energy efficiency wouldn't be
appropriate
thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
question in most cases they will be
appropriate but there are will be
properties where it won't be possible to
do that
not just in new builds but if we've got
older bills for example if you've got an
older build that has got a cement floor
it's going to be much more destructive
to remove that cement floor
and to
transport it and then destroy that
flooring than it is to put in um cost
efficiency
so um
most of the times it will be a case of
that we will be able to put them in but
again it's
i say this over and over again it's a
case of cost
and it's a balance between uh how much
we spend on actually retrofitting
properties and the new ones that are
coming forward as well as providing a
home for those that need a roof over
their head so there's a balance to be
had there so we need to be mindful of
that when we come to setting budgets
uh thank you thank you i appreciate that
this bit is under section of building
and buying new counter homes not
referring to retrofitting so
thank you chairman uh thank you council
jameson for the for the question
apologies if the report is not clear i
think the reference to where appropriate
is in relation to in fact modern methods
of construction where
in fact depending on the design guide
and the
program
you could see more traditionally built
homes or you could see modern methods of
construction perhaps in confined sites
or
or sites where
actually mmc lends itself
we've got an example in mid-south at the
moment where we're developing a scheme
in the rear area of a a councilwoman
property to provide a modern method of
construction for rough sleepers to live
in for up to two years as they're
supported back into to to ten years that
that site is confined to nature is an
example where mmc is appropriate
hinton
thank you mr chairman
we've heard in the past about the
backlog of
repairs and
work that's needed on our properties but
there's no mention of it anywhere in
this uh this paper don't think that
would be something that ought to be
included in the work plan as to how
we're going to catch up on our backlog
and make sure it doesn't occur again
thank you councillor hinton that's
actually getting into the finer detail
and that will come out in an action plan
that follows through with the hra
business plan um it is actually referred
to um it's referred to in 4.8 of the
priorities investing in our homes 4.13
climate change and 4.23 improv improving
service to our tenants but what you're
referring to is the finer detail there
is a lot of work going on in the repair
service team and it's true that it has
been facing its challenges
if you think back
two years ago for 12 months we couldn't
even
get into properties to
undertake minor repairs and then also
further on from that another 12 months
where residents were reluctant to let us
into their property to undertake those
repairs so it has created a backlog and
also it's been really difficult to get
materials and obviously issues with
staff sickness so it's got its
challenges there is a lot of work going
on and for example um
improved engagement with our tenants
together with utilizing technology
scheduling software and void management
software more efficient ways to access
materials so with these in place and
hopefully continue lifting the covered
restrictions we will start to see an
improvement bearing in mind we've also
got a new corporate manager on building
services who's got a lot of ideas coming
forward so we definitely members will
see an improvement in our repair
services within a six month period
thank you
um
thank you mr chairman uh
right
one of my questions have been uh
answered already
um
regarding the repairs i won't favor that
one again um but on page 63
um
4.11
ensure our homes exceed tenants
expectations this includes the fabric
and condition of the homes
um
how are we going to
inform
the tenants that we we have listened to
them because you emphasized that word
quite a few times
and i know you listen to them and you
know i listen to them but i do wonder
whether our officers listen to to you us
and the tenants so i'd like to know how
we're going to
inform people they are being listened to
because if you go over the page then to
page 64
and you come down to
4.24 again it refers to we do need to
make sure
that
we are achieving this because we have
had the problems in the past and you've
worked hard and officers have worked
hard but it doesn't seem to be getting
through to the tenants they're still
complaining they're still saying that
we're not reacting quickly enough
so
i'd just like to be assured that um
you will be listening the officers will
be listening and we will be informing
the the
residents that we're going to do a b or
c thank you
thank you councillor beer
um yeah we do have a um you'll recall a
few years ago we had a housing board
we reviewed that in 2017
and we developed a new model with a a
tenant sounding board which is working
really well up to date so that's one um
platform that we use to inform our
tenants we could do with more take up of
tenants wanting to sit on that
particular sounding board including
younger people we have a problem in
engaging with younger people that's
where we need to focus our efforts um on
that particular age group
we do a electronic newsletter to all our
tenants
and we obviously talk to them when we go
out and about and let the safer
neighbourhood team will talk to our
tenants when we go out so there are
several ways of engaging with them and i
can assure you that is a priority to
start engaging the uh social white
housing paper makes it very very clear
that that's what we've got to do so we
will be doing that i hope that answers
your question thank you
yes and macron
thank you mr chairman uh paragraph 4.12
on page 63 refers to enhanced void
standards
to ensure that we don't have voids
lasting so long and it suggested that
we're going to focus on quality rather
than cost and time
a lot of work was done over the last few
years in the voids project and it saw
significant results we have improved
void times
quite massively i'd like to be assured
that we're not going to completely uh
not say throw the baby out of the bath
water but
that we are going to continue to monitor
those void times and with a view to
keeping that performance level i can
understand quality matters but quantity
is also a matter of
a measurement that you can actually
define and it is easy to have a defined
measurement so i'd like to make sure we
don't lose the good work already done
thank you councillor mcgraw there was a
clear steer from members to focus on how
many days and you're absolutely right i
think we need we focused on that time
that target rather than the quality
we've now moved away from that yes we
will continue to keep an eye on on our
voice
but quality will also be an aspect and i
think also it's fair to mention with our
voice we're taking a very proactive
approach and um where we've got voids
that are going to cost a lot to repair
and they're on a site that actually is
primed for development
and so we will look at whether we
demolish those properties and build
more homes now two examples of that is
is shopli where we demolished two
bungalows and we built eight lovely new
bungalows and i was privileged to hand
the keys over those only a few months
ago and i can tell you the tenants that
receive those keys were very grateful
for those for having that those new
homes and then just recently a few weeks
ago brantham that's why alice has got a
smile on his face
we knocked down two homes in brampton
and the site allowed us to build nine
new homes for our tenants so we're also
taking a very proactive approach in
regards to voids
council lindsay
thank you chair um
there's yeah loads in this
that i'm pleased to see um
but um
and particularly in
the emphasis on retrofitting which is so
important we're going to meet our
climate commitments
the one area i'm sort of uncomfortable
with is
the vagueness of the the new builds when
it comes to
building and buying new council homes
we've got 4.18
and
um
some sort of
nice words about quality design but i
mean
the fact is
um and some of my fellow councillors who
represent lebanon will well no there's
there's a
there's a
a new uh relatively new
um group of houses there that were built
by the community land trust
that come to a far higher near passive
house standard
i find it embarrassing that
that the council are lagging behind a
community land trust so my question is
can we have some
assurance that we're going to
not just have
some good quality design but actually
do some exemplar
buildings when we come to building
council houses
that are near passive household passive
house standard
thank you
yeah we are as i have alluded to earlier
we are developing a design guide and
specification and that's by nowhere no
way
brief it sets it out very clearly what
our aspirations are those aspirations
might not always be met because there
again it may come down to cost and as
i've said before it's a balance between
cost of retrofitting energy efficiency
and providing new homes but i don't know
i think the design guide is coming to
cabinet and then onto four council in
the spring so you will see from their
counsellings that we're very very much
on board for that
particular retrofitting style
sorry which was a bit you referred to
just now
nowhere and
so i didn't i just didn't catch
it in my introduction i referred to um
the
development of a new build design guide
and technical specification
which will be coming to cabinet and then
onto full council
in early spring
i'm going to ask a question that i
thought councilor beer was going to ask
and it's
concerning 9.7 where it says lack of car
parking was the issue tenants were most
unhappy about
and i remember some years ago council of
beer's support
for the provision of additional car
parking and he was kind enough to
support my bid for additional parking in
monks ely which was in my ward at the
time
where they benefited from
a couple of new areas
to help ease congestion on the road
where um we have um council flats
council housing but um there are also
privately owned houses that have been
brought under the right to buy
and i seem to recall that the funding of
that came partly from the housing
revenue account
and partly from the general fund
balanced according to the
the benefit that would be achieved
um the only reference i can find in here
um to what we might do to to answer that
question um what what are we going to do
about car parking that's what they're
most unhappy about the only thing i can
find is at 4.29
where we say we might be able to
demolish some garages um possibly
provide some parking possibly provide
some housing on those sites or possibly
um
move it into sort of an amenity land
area we can't do all three in the same
place
so i'm just wondering if if that is what
tenants were most unhappy about
when we produce this document are we
actually going to be looking at ways
that we can introduce new parking areas
on existing council estates thank you
thank you councillor yeah you're
absolutely right
members and i know of beer has raised
this on many a time and tenants as well
it's a real problem parking and it's not
it's not just in sudbury it's not just
in baber it's a national problem however
it is our problem and what we look we're
looking at is we've got the parking
strategy that will be coming forward
they'll be looking at on street and off
street parking so hopefully they may
come up with some solutions there's also
the review of our garage sites which is
coming forward again a report will be
coming to cabinet very soon on where
it's going to be and possible to
demolish garages and
provide extra parking spaces
i see in berries and edmonds i see a
piece in the paper today that they're
looking at similar situations as well so
i've taken a copy of that so it's very
much on our agenda it is
identified actually in 4.27 and 4.30
improving our neighborhood but there
again you're getting into the finer
detail what we need to do is get the hra
business case approved and then we can
look at what solutions we can come up
with if indeed the parking strategy
review doesn't come up with any
solutions to it okay
um thank you chet um i was going to ask
a similar question to councillor arthy
so i'll wait for the debate uh just to
make the point thank you
thank you chairman at the risk of being
controversial but i'm sure jan cancer
osborne will
love this one
as a small rural
district council is it possible that one
day we might escape
the dreadful gateway to home choice
method of allocating our lovely homes
thank you
thank you councillor herren there's a
white elephant in the room isn't it we
were going to we were actually going to
review this and then covid um came into
place and so it it took a back seat
um and then we started to look at it
more carefully
and our corporate manager that we lost
um
heather who unfortunately left us um was
chairing the
gateway partnership board i'm not sure
if she's still in that position but she
was very much mindful of concerns raised
by councillors including my own concerns
the problem is when we did look at it to
come out of that gateway which is a
partnership of seven other local
authorities would be extremely costly
extremely costly so you know there again
it becomes a balance of do we want to
spend
a amount of money and also the resource
time as well in looking at other ways to
allocate our homes when in some ways
gateway works well i think what we need
to do is we need to look at the
allocation policy itself
there again it could be difficult
because you've got other seven other
partners that would have to agree to any
amendments we wanted to make to it but i
think rather than say look we're going
to move out of gateway go on to another
system i think we need to look at how we
can improve the system that we've
currently got
patience
so i shall move
on to debate
um
you
will have allowed to speak for once for
three minutes
and this
and this will be timed
thank you who would like to start
council medally baron might as well
continue where i was um
i i'd like to refer to that paragraph
also 9.7 that's on page 68. it talks
about the lack of car parking being the
issue most tenants are unhappy with and
i think it must be linked to the the
following bullet point
um staff and members um felt
neighborhoods looked untidy or unkempt
and poorly maintained because so many
vehicles do park on verges and churn up
the
the earth and and you can't see the
grass so it's an important having the
grass it's just just ends up looking
very untidy with um cars quite
unhaphazardly
um but on the past plus side that must
be a testament to our housing if that's
the biggest problem our tenants have got
so
um but i think that must be addressed in
a as we
as we've got our parking strategy uh
looking at this issue and it's not just
sufficient to
look at the garage sites and say well
they would form good
alternative parking arrangements because
i know from many of my residents who
have trade vehicles
they
um are scared about parking further away
from their their homes because of the
break-ins that they suffer
um putting them out of work for the next
day if their their work fan is is is
damaged and their tools have gone
so um i know a lot of my residents want
to
um release the
often green spaces that are in the front
of their tenanted properties and and
you know have parking available where
they can be have a reasonable chance of
um deterring thefts and uh and break-ins
um so i just want to
sort of make sure that um
the parking strategy
is uh
fed into
to this work that you're doing on this
housing housing business plan
okay i apologize ah thank you mr
chairman i recall uh we received a an
extensive briefing actually i was very
impressed with this briefing on the
entire issue of housing the housing
revenue account and specifically these
plans from a variety of members from the
the housing offices um
i was impressed
more than anything with the ambition of
it and the breadth uh it covered in fact
every single aspect that you could wish
now this is only a starting point but it
seems quite obvious we need to develop
this sort of plan uh i think housing
provide provision of housing is one of
the prime responsibilities of a local
authority like ourselves and there was a
period of 25 to 30 years where that
provision disappeared almost completely
i'm very glad to see that we've reversed
that trend and i look forward to that
continuing so i'll be supporting this
recommendation both these
recommendations completely thank you
thank you mr chairman um
ken salafi i hadn't forgotten my head
got it marked and i was going to do it
in debate which is what i'm going to do
but it is to do with the park and i'd
like to know what
input and
concerns been put in by the housing
department
into the park and strategy because one
of the big problems
um as you can see the thames fear is
their parthen ability
and there are lots of areas outside some
of these
properties
where there's a green verge
which could be utilized as a park an
area
it doesn't mean to say that we lose all
our green areas on our estates because
that wouldn't be sensible
but if they're being churned up now
surely they ought to be earmarked to
have a look at and see whether we can
incorporate them into a hard surface
which would one make it look tidier um i
think at the end of the day this is the
biggest problems that our cancer house
tenants are facing look around the
estates they've all got too many cars
we can't stop that
we we can't cope for all of them
whatever we think they're not all going
to get on their bikes so they're not all
going to get on public transport they're
not all going to walk
and cycle to work they are going to have
cars and we should embrace this
and we should try and
help them where we can there are lots of
areas on the estates where this could
happen quite easily
but it's the action to get anything done
we take such a long time
we were winning a little while ago with
a particular officer going around our
estates
and solving lots of the problems and
unfortunately the powers that be decided
they didn't want to go down that road
certainly i as a local councillor felt
that that was the right course of action
and we should have continued it
but we are where we are so can i be
assured that
you're going to have involvement that
you are going to try and uh do some of
these parking and situations because you
go down this the state roads and you can
see where the grass has churned up and a
little bit of foresight and um
perhaps not extra concrete but there
must be other ways we can do it where we
could make a hard surface
so that they can park some of these cars
off the road and
certainly um alleviate the roads so that
they can be used for traffic when it's
necessary thank you
councilman
sorry
sorry mr chairman am i always counsellor
dawson i seem to have got councillor
dawson
on here
you've gone right thank you thank you
very much mr chairman um i would have
thought my green uh colleagues would
have
replied to cancer beer
i do not
disagree with you at all
however
we do need to look at car parking
in a way that is also green
because if you're going to take up all
the green areas and i know council
councillor beer said no
if you take up all the green areas first
of all
that will need
then to be a reassessing for public
realm
as to what green space is available per
head of population
then there's the issue of too much hard
standing
will actually make water runoff even
more difficult in some areas
so i think that
looking at car parking is absolutely
fine however it needs to be done i think
with the green agenda in mind and i'm
sorry that my green colleagues across
the road as it were have not brought
that up but i have and i never know what
it's called but there's this wonderful
honeycomb stuff that you actually put
down on
free draining
thank you
yes but free draining concrete base
and it can actually have grass growing
through it so there's the benefits of
both but um but council a bit i do agree
with you we need to do something but it
needs to be the right thing
thank you
yeah just uh to pick up on a couple of
points castle maybe has made i i think
um
most of us would would agree with
council appear the situation with
parking in some areas is
is getting quite critical it's it's
upsetting the residents um it's it's
making the states look um
pretty pretty unpleasant in in places
but i will take issue castle maybe um
some of these areas are no longer green
they're just mud um and uh with the best
of the world i think the only thing is a
porous surface
not one that allows grass to grow
through i don't think that will that
will work i don't think the grass will
grow through but we need to have proper
porous surfaces
that are hard hard surfaces but allow
the water to drain through and and that
really is is the only solution and we do
need as councillor beerus says we do
need to look at this
with a lot more urgency than i think we
have been doing so up until now
thank you thank you
sorry did you sorry
um
i just wanted to respond to your
challenge that's the main reason
you um teased me into it uh no the
reason i haven't responded is because i
don't think we're
it's such a big issue a parking strategy
is only going to deal with parking it's
not going to deal with transport and
that's the real problem
we have a duty to provide housing to
tenants we don't have a duty to provide
parking for them but tenants have a
right to have decent transport to get
where they want to go
the buses if you look around submarine
corner been cut to nothing um
and all the areas where we have council
houses buses are virtually non-existent
now i know the argument's going to be
we're not a transport authority
therefore it's nothing to do with us gav
wash our hands of it we shouldn't be
doing that there's an expense to
providing car parking just as an expense
providing buses and if you keep on
saying to people well now you've got
three cars we'll provide more parking
for you
where does it end where do you stop that
you know does yeah 25 30 yeah well i'm
sure councilman would love that but the
rest of us and the rate payers
wouldn't
uh because there's the costs
not just to us and to rate payers but to
the planet
are endless the answer that providing
more car parking spaces is not the only
answer
providing decent transport and looking
at ways to encourage buses
is part of the answer
and we need a we need a transport
strategy not just a car park strategy
thank you
um yes
council lindsay's partly actually
correct um but the problem with this
is that the parking consultation is is
has been was established
over a year ago
by my predecessor and it's about looking
going forward and
actually interesting one of the
uh one of the
questions that came back is whilst we
might change transport
people have very habitual and they want
to use their cars so um it's all very
well saying well we want to have buses
and everything but people actually
aren't using them because of the habits
they've
inherited and don't want to change so we
have to really think this through quite
clearly
but what i mean i have said you know i
only got the paper back last night i was
reading it till two in the morning and
might rest assured um that everyone will
be having input into this parking
consultation but it is very much about
availability of space etc green issues
and those actually didn't come out as
being particularly
of the high priority it's all about
availability and what is there
so in due course in the next few weeks
you will be seeing what has come back
and it's all about people's opinions
it's not um there were no clear
um i think the parameters might have
been perhaps thought about um
that we've gone past that
so you will be getting the feedback from
that and then that's when we will come
back with the advice which hopefully um
you will always have the opportunity to
give more input at that stage
thank you chairman i was going to open
another can of worms but i will comment
on that one um
what is the problem here is it that we
don't have enough car parking is it that
we have too many cars
or has just been mentioned is it that
our public bus service has just totally
collapsed
even a village like oxford has virtually
no buses anymore
um some of my rule which is just one or
two a week everybody has to have one two
or three cars and
that is the problem um you've got to
tackle it probably from that end
because people just have no choice and
even the council has often has three
cars now and um
that is the times we are living in and
that is the root of the problem
the other kind of worms i was going to
open um is voids chairman and um
you know i'm as guilty as anybody when i
was on overbird scrutiny we championed
getting it down getting it down it was
like being top of the premiership or can
we get it any quicker but um
there is a downsize to this and i've
sort of um
hit into that quite badly we do have to
make sure in cutting this time that the
houses are
fit to be hired
and also especially um when we show
people around they should be in a good
condition that somebody would want to
live there
and some of our houses become voids
because people die
people are evicted or move out in
horrible circumstances
i raise this now and i have sorted it
and um settled it in my own way but
recently i had a case where a couple
were
shown round the house where somebody had
died and it looked as if it had been
absolutely
ransacked and we have to be careful and
these people come out of a tied house
chairman and
desperate need of housing but they were
quite shocked they were used to
farming people they were used to seeing
things butchered in the sink and
everything else he was a game keeper but
um they were quite traumatized by what
they saw in this house and
including the deceased's false teeth
laying around in various rooms so i
think
in our um challenges to get the time
down please just
be a bit sensitive and be a bit careful
that when people are shown the houses
are
actually fit to be let at that time
because that doesn't look good either so
um
just i'm not criticizing anybody it has
been sorted but there can be a downside
to our
um
challenge to get things done quicker i
just thought good time to raise that
chairman and for god's sake do something
about the lack of buses
who's currently looking at the transport
set up at some point
in fact there's a there's a
a team that's set up to to look at it
i would just like to add that the green
spaces that counselor lindsay talks
about
i have been and like most of you here
have traveled around
i'm afraid the utility services don't do
the green spaces any good at all
they are always digging stuff up and
where are they bargaining to do that
on those green spaces so
anyway that's my two pennies
thank you um
council osborne is there anything you
wish to add
yes
on that one
um yeah briefly i am pleased that we've
had a good and healthy debate a very
healthy debate and members comments are
noted specifically on parking and on
voids
this approach is the way forward
in developing our revised hra with the
drivers being those identified by our
tenants our members and the social
housing white paper and i'd like to take
this opportunity to thank our tenants
and our members for engaging in this
process to get where we are today
and also thank you to our officers in
the housing team for their continued
commitment and hard work thank you mr
chairman
[Applause]
yeah
i'd also make uh
reference to our the housing team i
think they've been excellent and
um gavin fisk has done a wonderful
few years with with the housing thank
you gabby
last one
um
thank you
right thanks chair um the only thing
i'll say i i
understand about the new build and uh
the cost and everything else
about being green
my one concern is and i've brought it up
before maybe maybe not the right agenda
but
um there's a lot of houses up well two
or three i know which are local to me
which stand empty and they've stood
empty for two years and uh
there's people um live either side of
these houses so these houses are
could be done up and made habitable
so i believe these houses need to be
done and i don't think there's an excuse
that they stand empty unless people
need them
it's very unusual and it's not in our
favor because we need to get people off
the housing register to leave houses
empty there are situations with a void
if somebody for example has gone into
care
there's no way we can remove that
tenancy until that person has confirmed
that they've gone into permanent care so
sometimes that can go on for years and
there's absolutely nothing we can do
about it but i will ask
gavin if he's got any more to add on
that
thank you mr chairman just a
point of information really on the
uh
parking and still looking green if you'd
like to google grass creek you can find
that there's a simple system out there
it's used a lot around blocks of flats
so that
turntable ladders can park on what is
looks like grass but not sink in when
they're trying to uh put out fires
etcetera but it cannot it's often done
with concrete blocks but it can also be
done with recycled plastic blocks
so it's a environmentally friendly
system as well
right uh thanks for jan's response but
um the houses that i i personally know
about
there's no one going into a home they've
been unoccupied
um
tenant these belong to the council the
tenants leave it live either side of
these properties
um
at some point someone would have owned
one of them and the council would have
bought it and that will stand there
empty so
it's just not a situation that should be
happening
they should be occupied
thank you
i'd now like to
ask the corporate manager governance and
civic office to conduct the electronic
vote
thank you chair that vote is now
open and showing in blue if you could
cast your votes please
councillor lindsay can i take your vote
please
thank you
are you still having problems
chair that is 29 4 that is unanimous
thank you
that's carried thank you very much
members
uh i'd like to go to uh item 11
the draft committee timetable for 2223
i'd like to invite council wall to
introduce paper bc 2127
and to remove and to move the
recommendation in the report
uh thank you chair uh just a brief
introduction the um
this is for the committee timetable for
uh the fourth coming year 22 to 23. um
there is
an amendment to to the appendix to the
paper with the timetable inlets in your
table papers
um this evening
i just want to draw your attention to a
couple of things um
firstly the amendment that
the table paper refers to
is the fact that uh in may
2023 the initial version of the appendix
did not have our
baby annual council meeting that's now
been corrected
so that's in
in the supplement um the other thing i
just want to draw your attention to is
is the fact that um
you'll see that
as we have discussed and promised there
are additional meetings
that are in the schedule for so that we
have monthly
council meetings um
for conducting the additional business
that we promised we would do uh to allow
members to have a greater input into
various topics so we've now got annual
uh so we've now got monthly council
meetings in this schedule so i'd like to
propose the recommendations and uh
thanks
i just
just mentioned well i just really
pointed
that we have got a meeting on the 23rd
of august
scheduled
by the looks of it
it would interrupt my
time off
which is very dear to me
um
and i just wonder whether that is uh
i said it does say provisional
how provisional is provisional
i'm very concerned
about this
that is one of the additional meetings
that we've put into the schedule they're
all registered as provisional at the
moment
obviously depending on whether there is
actually any business to conduct then
those meetings may or may not take place
but um
we've done it so that every month is
covered
um
i guess with august most people might
well want to go on holiday um
you'll be off on your uh camping trips
around the uk probably
i think yeah uh so um
we'll we'll have to see we'll play it by
ears provisional so um we'll
to determine whether that will happen or
not
the the only thing that is um there is
obviously you know when you're an
organized person like myself and you
then go ahead
it is slightly frustrating when you uh
obviously leave a gap in your holiday
provision
to have a council meeting then cancelled
so if we are going to cancel them could
we cancel them at least two months ahead
but
council barrett um
you
you have leader this is only
you do have sufficient notice you can
book your holiday around it perhaps if
you really wanted to attend
are there any other questions
oh counter beer
mr chairman um i didn't realize that
there's been a gender paper sent through
that's altered these dates so could you
just remind me which dates have changed
from the dates that are printed on page
73 and 74 of the
agenda
yes council of beer um
it is uh for
may 23rd uh 23rd of may 2023
there was a mistake
there which said it had the um overview
and scrutiny down twice it
but now it's been corrected so that the
annual council meeting is there
there's no if there's no other questions
members
i'd like to uh ask our
corporate manager governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if you can cast your votes thank
you
councillor lindsay can i take your vote
thank you
um
um chair that issue
unanimous for thank you thank you sir
carrie thank you
i'd now like to turn to
number 12
the bc 2128 political balance and
composition of committees
i refer to the amended appendix a in the
table papers and i would like to invite
the monitoring office to introduce a
report
thank you chairman
i'm pleased to present the revised
political balances and committee places
following two changes to the political
groupings
councillor owen who was previously an
ungrouped councillor has now joined with
members of the green group to form the
green and labour group
councillor maybe has left the
independent group and rejoined the
conservative group
the revised political balances and
committee places has been included at
appendix a to the report
the changes are that the independent
group has lost a seat on the planning
committee and the conservative group has
gained that seat
and that the previously unallocated seat
on the planning committee has now been
allocated to the green and labor group
chairman i'm very happy to answer any
any questions on the report and would
ask for a proposer and seconder for the
recommendation thank you
proposed
jonathan um cancer wall
yeah there's just one um on
paragraph 3.2 it still says that baber
has one ungrouped member of the council
okay thanks
so
i'd like to ask the
governance officer
civic office to conduct the electronic
vote thank you
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if you can cast your vote thank
you
councillor lindsay can i take your vote
thank you
thank you chair that vote is unanimous
for
thank you
we're up to 13 of them
item 13 council report appointments
uh council is asked to approve the
appointments to committee as detailed on
the agenda
thank you chairman as there are quite a
few uh changes i just thought i'd run
through them for councillors so that
you're all clear on on where the changes
have been made and also i've been
notified of a few um late ones this
evening so um i just will run through
the list and if i have got anything
wrong if you could shout at the relevant
point and so we make sure that we're all
very clear on who's been appointed to
the various places so councillor owen is
staying on the planning committee but
changing from an ungrouped member to the
green and labour group member
councillor mabry is joining the planning
committee and councillor parker will be
removed from the planning committee
councillor mabry is replacing councillor
dawson on licensing and regulatory
committee so in effect is staying on but
is now taking the conservative seat and
councillor parker will be filling the
independent group vacancy on the
licensing and regulatory committee left
by councillor mabry
councillor hinton will be filling the
independent group vacancy on the
overview and scrutiny committee and
chairman finally i would just like to
report to the council that there is a
green and labor group vacancy on the
joint audit and standards committee and
hopefully that was all correct thank you
chairman thank you
do anybody want to
councillor busby
yes chair just there seems to be a lot
of changing particularly on the other
side of the uh house there people coming
in and out i just wonder whether they
recognize what a party is
i don't know if they do david but boris
does
thank you that's enough thank you
yeah i'd like to go to vote now so i'll
ask our governance and civic officer
to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now going
to be showing in blue if you can cast
your vote thank you councillor barrett's
got his hand up awesome
i'll take it
okay
um
okay chair that is unanimously formed
so that is carried
can i just say um
thank you all members for
a good evening
and
and a good time scale thank you very
much
item 14 motions on notice
thank you thank you
the date of the next council meeting
will be
on monday the 21st of february
at 5 30 so
i now close the meeting thank you